so I guess jay-z kind of called out
Colin Kapernick for his workout I think
you probably know more about this than I
do
so Kaepernick's been out a league for
three years right he's gone she says
he's getting ready the NFL I see both
sides the NFL was like right let's go
we're gonna give you a workout they
invite 20 teams that Atlantic Falcons
practice facilities it's orchestrated
he's gonna have all these workouts so
people and teams can see him well Cap'n
Kaepernick want his team and his people
in there and NFL which they don't
usually allow goes no hold up you can't
have all these people in here where you
have are teaming that they come on they
want to regulate what cameras what media
was gonna be on Kaepernick went we want
full transparency so I'm not gonna do it
here I'm gonna do it over here now
if you just wanna play football you're
probably not gonna do that right because
all 28 or 32 teams were gonna show up I
think 20 teams have third you were gonna
show up give look at you give you an
opportunity but he went hold up I can't
have my team in there [ __ ] I'm doing
over here now but I say over here I mean
an hour so the NFL teams right we're not
driving in an hour
eight teams did they said he did
actually look really good as an elite
throwing arm but you know you kind of
shoot it on your opportunity they also
wanted to sign like this large contract
which they gave him day of he's like now
hold up I'm gonna sign all this and in
the contract from what I heard is by him
signing that it would it make him how he
can't go back and sue the NFL for
missing all that work so in the contract
was little CD so he's like am I sign a
contract B I'm not letting limit who
comes in and out so I'm gonna do it over
here I'm with all this is that the NFL
can go okay like the NFL doesn't need
Colin Kaepernick absolutely not damn and
I think one the reach so for those of
you don't know how the NFL works every
Tuesday literally every Tuesday because
team guys get hurt they bring in guys
try out for the team I didn't know he'll
bring guys in to you know though they
can bring out throughout the season they
bring guys in huh so what's interesting
the jobs never say [ __ ] here no never
so but they could all these teams who
are interested could have brought him in
any tuesday to work him out
right it's weird they orchestrated this
big kind of Atlantic Falcons worked out
invite all the teams people think is
because
he has relationship with the NFL he
forced them to do it so but I see both
sides but jay-z's disappointed and
jay-z's a liaison for the NFL now
and so one help about to help the
relationship with African Americans and
the culture and stuff like that is the
liaison so to jay-z's point he's kinda
like hold up dude
we finally get your workout with 20
teams and you're worried about your team
coming in and the narrative like how bad
do you want play football right when I
first also think how bad do you want
play football dude come on all 20 do you
know more about this new boy said that
Khan Cabernet was wasn't doing that well
anyway he was doing well but doing well
in quarterback yeah the problem is yeah
I don't know if he be starter now that
like the Bears could use him the Broncos
could use him Miami there's a few teams
who definitely the Bears Carolina he
could probably fit on a team it's just
what did jay-z say and jay-z was really
disappointed in him moving the workout
elsewhere and he says that he believes
that Colin Kaepernick did it more as a
PR stunt than for him to actually get
back onto the team I think jay-z is just
really upset by him pulling all these
strings trying to get this open workout
with all these teams for Colin
Kaepernick only to have him kind of make
a big deal out of the situation and then
move the work out to somewhere else
because now he feels like it's a
publicity stunt it's not necessarily
about getting him back into footballing
if it was just about football he
would've shut up and just went to that
workout and see what happens but it's
like more you know yeah I don't know
help Collins handle it too like you
already see him out there either like
moving the needle as far as equal rights
and police brutality like he's not
giving out they're giving speeches
around City City go on tour you know
going to where there's actual issues so
I don't know man I don't know I can
understand how jay-z and the another and
Scouts like dude [ __ ] this guy I'm holed
up we show up and then you wanted an
hour this way so our distraction right
it's also of the biggest yeah and you
will have I'll tell you this in America
if Colin Kaepernick is on your team
you're you're not gonna you're gonna
piss off of sizeable portion of your
population which is fine as you want to
do that but also at the minute he starts
doing poorly we're gonna take even more
in Tebow suffers from the same
is when you have that when you're when
your name is bigger than football when
you're a backup or whatever it is it
puts so much more pressure on the team
it just puts so much more scrutiny and
like I bought them things why'd you
why'd you hire him if you're not doing
well if you want a Super Bowl great but
you know well where is if cons number
one goes to play football he would have
done this hmm and Steve if you have you
seen what Steven Naismith said because
the other guy the safety I forget his
name
there's a safety who also too can kneel
with him put up Steve Naismith
scrutinizes Kaepernick but there's a
safety who did it oh dude but the guy
went out Steve Naismith don't [ __ ] with
Steve Nash dude wait do you see these
tweets now he leered us he lit him up so
then so let me get this straight
worse hairline ever whatever Colin
Kaepernick has been working out all of
this time him people in this camp his
closed ones loved ones everybody talked
about he wants to play football he wants
to play football he's ready to play just
give him the chance so what does the NFL
do recognizing that teams need a shield
because they need something to hide
behind because they know that guess what
if we bring this brother in for a
workout and we don't like him or we
don't want him who knows what we're
going to get accused of we need cover so
the NFL provides that I have no doubt
jay-z's involved I have no doubt Roger
Goodell is involved I have no doubt
there's a host of people of bobble thank
you all of that this man one of the
chants 25 teams show up in Georgia at
the Atlanta Falcons practice facility
stayed at our facility NFL personnel
equipment everything video everything
and what does Colin Kaepernick do not
Tuesday when he found out about it now
Wednesday
day Saturday three hours before the
workout because of some issue with a
liability waiver collar Catholic wants
to change the venue
Kylie Kaplan wants his own receivers
Colin captive was the video thinks
himself Colin Kaepernick wants the media
this collar Catholic comedian can't find
him he's got no interviews
he talked to nobody I mean you can't
find him but he wants to do in it he
wants the media available now hosted
excellent you see you see he don't want
to play not like his camera angle he
wants to be a martyr that's right but
guess what I love it any working this
time all of us believe that Colin
Kaepernick would have showed out and if
he had showed out I'm here to tell you
you're the hunter I believe he would
have had a job inside of two weeks agree
the burial is long like but it didn't
happen cuz he didn't show he wanted to
show up to a high school in Georgia now
you get out of here and it's the guy who
also took kidney authy I forget his name
go back it's on social media Colin
Kaepernick no no not call it nope nope
nope no it's Steven a Smith
oair Creed Stevie Smith oh there you go
Fox News the middle one dude and see
where it just drops that's on this dude
so Eric Reid is the guy who also sat out
with him and his plane then I felt
currently so Eric Reid puts at Steven
Naismith tap-dancing for the NFL like I
know what that is
damn straight Colin wants to control the
narrative he's supposed to trust the
organization that black ball to him and
has done absolutely nothing in good
faith born on Tuesday just not last
Tuesday at Steven Naismith right so
Steven Smith goes keeps throwing out
don't play the video here he goes dude
mark
mark said if you're not careful this is
Eric Rita's have you hatin the people
who are being oppressed and loving the
people who are doing the oppressing you
embody this quote you Malcolm Jenkins
and jay-z prance around doing the NFL's
bidding to try to bury calm I stand for
truth and justice above all else you're
missing you are mistaken by thinking
that because you are anybody is black
that you are spared from my criticism
especially when you've been so blatantly
on the NFL side and corrupting her own
their own process to hinder Colin's
employment now look what does scream a
certain right Stephen a Smith the more
you talk the more ridiculous you sound
they read actually it's worse than I
thought since you're the one tweeting to
me hours before a damn game and speaking
of the game weren't you in Atlanta in
attendance for Kaepernick's workout
yesterday before having to leave early
to play it for a team in a league you're
feeling so oppressed by wasn't that you
just ask and hold on I have more the
same Malcolm X who we all Revere for
life
you just bought up you just brought up
acknowledged there were slight error
there were slight errors in his thinking
you didn't bring that up you Eric Reid
went through the same process cap was
supposed to go through and you're still
on you're still playing on Sunday but
you didn't bring that up and unlike you
walking around and doing nothing but
bitching at every turn myself and many
others in the media have religiously
called out the NFL for blackballing
cap we're religiously highlight we've
religiously highlighted the unfairness
of it all and some of us have worked
behind the scenes trying to help jay-z
and others in their quest to get cap
back in the league meanwhile what does
he agree doing complaining like he wants
to be on First Take failing to stop the
run on Sundays taking money and a
[ __ ] about the NFL whatever talking
[ __ ] about it the the NFL at every
turn but asking for that check no doubt
yes I'm the one tap-dancing why because
I'm gainfully employed while trying to
remind youngsters out there of the
pitfalls at lying wait meanwhile Someone
Like You continues to throw
professionalism decorum and decency into
the white into the wind sending folks
down a dead-end path all because your
boy isn't getting precisely his way when
no one gets their way so who's the
sellout guess what it's neither of us we
just have a difference of opinion I
still respect the hell out of you
immature belligerent self but I'm going
to call it like I see it
cabinet made a mistake the way he
handled all this if he really wanted a
job in the NFL period and your
contribution to all of this doesn't help
it hurts anything about you being wrong
it's about you needing to grow the hell
up your decision your life do you yeah
yeah do we all have a different opinion
ice but yeah keep going
I've been ready for three years I've
been I for three years we're waiting for
the Thursday owners I'm just not buying
stop writing I'm not right there just I
see both ways but it's just like I think
he's an egomaniac and I think he's not
he's wait he's not I think he's I think
he's way more valuable by not playing
and he knows it and but at him keep
trying to dabble in and because then I
felt like cool here's twenty teams if
you want to play yours twenty teams
Atlanta Falcons do you think oh this is
ridiculous
you're divine for position on team your
you're a good player you're not a great
player I think if you're a GM or your
you're your own of a team you're like
hold up this guy's making it this
difficult to give him up never hire
never never I don't even know about what
he stand care about in the only nice
brutality no one wants that in the NFL
but you know I can deal with this and
they're not gonna deal with it so he
didn't get signed right I mean eight
teams showed up but I I just
significantly hurt his chances
no one's wants to deal with this I'd
like to see him play and see what
happens I'd love see him jump in with
Chicago or you know the Broncos we need
him now here's the question will he Neal
I don't know it's a he's just huge chat
I wouldn't sign him no I think he sounds
like a [ __ ] diva you know uh well I
don't know what he was like as a player
was he well-liked I don't know hmm I
don't know he's fallen for the for the
Niners for a while well we see Antonio
Brown come back all depends on his
assault charges yeah he's good enough
where they're gonna put up with it mmm
you know what best receivers all time
yeah
so that would be he's less of a
distraction than Colin he's like some
instruction column II don't want to
write a girlfriend but you know tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue okay what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]